before we start the meeting i'll read
out the emergency evacuation
announcement
should we be required to evacuate the
building would you please leave the
building via the hall entrance doors
turn right walk straight past the
canteen and through the external doors
on the right and out to the car park
which is our assembly point
please do not delay your evacuation to
collect any belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
council staff please note that this
meeting will be audio recorded
would you please switch off your mobiles
or turn them to silent
members there are four microphones on
the tables for use during the meeting
please pass these to each other as
necessary during the meeting
when i invite you to speak please wait
until there is a microphone in front of
you
before speaking as the microphones are
needed for the hearing loop and for the
audio recording
please use the hand gel and
antibacterial wipes on the tables if you
do touch the microphones
members voting will be done on a show of
hands in line with the constitution and
i will ask for a show of hands before
and then against recommendations those
abstaining from the voting will be noted
by officers
members before we start the meeting um i
hope you would uh
join me in sending our thoughts to the
people of ukraine at this difficult time
and i hope that there will be a speedy
return to a just peace in their country
thank you
moving on to the agenda agenda item one
apologies for absence we've received
apologies from council robin dre
councillor ian foster and councillor
ireland gadsden
the gender item two substitute members
councillor bob milner is substituting
for councillor dre and councillor julie
gooding for ireland gadsden
agenda item three number members
attending councillor simon woodson
moving on to agenda item four minutes of
the meeting held on the 8th of february
2022
members are the
minutes agreed
thank you those are agreed
gender item 5 to receive declarations of
interest are there any declarations of
interest members
sorry councillor newport
thank you chair um
i think
there's one item on the agenda which is
uh cctv and as a member of rayleigh town
council
um i may have an interest in that item
we'll move on to agenda item six which
is the community safety partnership
welcome to councillor williams the
portfolio holder for the community
uh inspector calder and louisa moss
assistant director people and
communities who have joined us this
evening for this item
council williams can i invite you please
to introduce the update on the work of
the community safety partnership
yeah thank you chairman thank you
chairman and members
this report updates the committee on the
delivery of the joint castle point and
rocha district community safety
partnership
over the last year and outlines the
draft
priorities for 2022-23
a small amount of pfcc grant monies
received continue
to focus on partnership projects that we
know work
sorry that we know work and the young
people program
i.e walk online and crucial crew have
now successfully adapted to the online
delivery which is more flexible for the
schools and has increased attendance
across all years
this
year crucial crew was delivered for the
first time online and focused as one
subject only
so as to reinforce messaging on what the
partnership knew was a topical issue i.e
tackling issues of exploitation linked
to county lines drug supply
you will note the partnership draft
priorities remain
in part
the same for next year with noticeable
addition of domestic abuse and violence
against women and girls as as we know
there is a lot of work ongoing
nationally and across essex to progress
this agenda
the essex safety advisory group
that the partnership sits on has only
just released its priorities and essex
police are also in the final stages of
their draft strategic approach
so over the coming months the essex
community safety network will work
together
to ensure consistency of approach
and incorporate actions into delivery
plans as they emerge
i will now hand over to inspector calder
who will know that
will no doubt update us
on the latest policing figures for our
district and reflect on how partnership
has worked from her team's perspective
thank you thank you
i'm not sure i need that but i'll do it
anyway thank you councillor
and thank you chair so good evening
everybody it's lovely to actually see
you again this year not so nice for me
last year when we were on teams i've had
a look at
the statistics in line with the
priorities from last year
and i'm going to focus in the main on
anti-social behavior what a funny time
this has been it's had a real impact on
our statistics
you'll be aware that essex police at the
moment have a high harm agenda
so i know that i've been in contact with
a number of councillors and a number of
people in the districts
around the the work that we're focusing
on at the moment so it is pertinent that
we look at violence against the person
and looking at the rochford data it
would be fair to say that we have had an
increase in offences that sit under
violence against the person
what i'm not going to do and what i'm
not able to do is
dissecting those figures is actually
really difficult to do because there are
so many different
offenses that sit under there as an
example stalking and harassment sits
under that banner
and so what we did do is a piece of work
or a couple of months ago where we found
that and this was done in consultation
with the csp where we did a piece of
mapping
and the mapping revealed that there was
approximately and i think i'm right in
saying 46 of those um violence against
the person crimes were around and
forgive me if that that figure is
slightly inaccurate i know i've got the
details here and i'll have a look at it
in a moment but around that figure was
around domestic abuse
and that seems like a really high figure
that is a figure that we do have a
specific team that focuses on for for
the whole of essex and for our area so
i'm not going to focus on violence
against the person other than to say it
is the main agenda that essex police are
focusing on at the moment because of the
level the increase around violence
that's force wide and we have seen
some quite horrific offenses throughout
the force but i don't know if there's
anybody that wants to ask me any
questions just about violence in the
first instance
mike
sorry
chair
i'm not very good at this
oh i'm so sorry i said i'm not very good
i just like to say that we we have
noticed the and social behavior locally
to uh to where we are and i've had a
brilliant response from
police and they have been on it the very
next day and continuing to visit places
in areas that i've experienced that so
thank you and your team that have done a
brilliant job because it has broken down
what was becoming a gang to collect and
and
thank you
thank you
council
thank you
kathy um
the fences against the person saying
there's an increased force wide is that
an actual increase or do you think it's
to do with changes in the way crime is
recorded and changes in legislation and
that was a real concern to me bringing
that to the meeting the figures exist so
i wanted to say that the figures are
there and they say that there has been
an increase but i actually do believe
that there has been changes that have
impacted on that figure i can't tell you
what the changes are in particular but i
do believe that that's the case because
the the increase is quite significant i
think the stalking and harassment and
all of the offences that come around
that are what's actually caused the
problem but i haven't done the fine
grain detail deep dive is that okay
councillor wilkinson
i've done it again i haven't finished
[Music]
good evening
um it's just a quick question you said
you would look to all the recent
statistics you've got but i tried to
search the essex police website and last
available
figures on there were from 2019
so there was nothing on there but then i
had a look at the house of commons
library
statistics
and
for knife crime which appears to be one
of the items on the list
um although essex police puts it into a
weapons category which could be anything
from like throwing a book at someone to
hit him with a machete
the actual knife crime has been listed
in this thing and it's actually doubled
inside three years
the occasion
yeah from the essex police district from
750 to 1500 and something and i was sort
of why there was no
figures produced by ethics police in the
last few years
i'm 100 with you councillor myers on
that one um
the knife crime it's really difficult to
scan through our statistics to find the
data around knife crime specifically
because what it generally is is it will
generally fall into a different type of
offence there may be an assault it might
be an offensive weapon it might be so
many different things so actually to
drill down and get that data is very
difficult what i would put down what i
would put that increase down to
is
operation septa we've been running for a
number of years now and it does bring a
focus around knife crime so i think that
there has been some um
and we i think the public engagement
around knife crime is a lot more now
than it ever used to be so i actually
think that's why we know more about
knife crime in our communities does that
make sense it does i just wondered why
the essex police hadn't published
anything for like three years really so
my understanding is there is a
website
police.co.uk
and that has whether it has fine-grained
detail statistics but it does give you
information about crime that's happening
in your area so that's where we
ask people to look now when we're
the only only problem that the
statistics have been bunched together
into weapons haven't they there's
nothing that says like knife crime like
or anything like that you've even got
weapons which covers everything as i say
yeah anything you want to pick up to
becomes a weapon so i should
nothing specific that was awesome no but
none of my data has specific knife crime
on it so i'm not able to give you that
information okay
i was going to follow on with asb stuff
because i have done a fair amount of
research around antisocial behavior if
that's in order
um so
i've looked up the dashboard around
antisocial behavior and it talks about
the last few years and in fact the last
month it was really interesting for me
to see that anti-social behavior
particularly in the rochford area has
been top of essex police's list
for this last month and in fact um
for the month before as well and it does
have a significant amount of antisocial
behavior happening i wanted to talk to
you about the sort of work that we've
been doing here
we have had quite a few incidents as the
statistics show and we have an operation
honduras where we are trying really hard
to identify some local young offenders
who have been causing us an amount of
grief over cherry orchard way and cherry
orchard park over at the airport indus
shopping estate and yes sorry
and and so what we have done is we've
already arrested three of the
individuals
and
forgive me i'm not up to speed on
whether they've actually achieved the
fourth arrest because that officer
wasn't on duty for me to speak to today
and we do have a file already together
to go through to the courts on that
i think that since we've done this work
we have seen a reduction in the amount
of asb that's been reported to police so
i think we have had some successes there
but it is something that we are
constantly working on
i'd like to reassure you we're also
working in schools to try to educate our
young people about
good and bad behavior to try to steer
them the right way and in fact um in on
the 25th of april i've actually asked
for forced support so that we can have a
week in this district in the rochford
rayleigh and castle point district so
i've got a whole week of support from
the force where i've asked that
we focus on engagement particularly with
our young people
whatever that looks like to try to steer
them in the right way so any ideas that
you may have please let me know
so we'll be working with youth agencies
and partners and schools
as well as more wider engagement just to
try to encourage young people to go the
right way we have
our engagement has reduced in the last
couple of years as i'm sure you can
appreciate because of covid and we've
really felt that but i'm also really
conscious that when we look at the
statistics it would appear that young
people more often than not
are
our suspect when it comes to an amount
of criminality so i think we need to do
something in both of those respects and
we're trying desperately hard to do that
work any ideas please let us know
you're indicating
yeah thank you i only just occurred for
a question here actually which probably
kathy could take back to the essex
police
um
i noticed when we were dealing with um
our research and crime in raleigh for
cctv we had problems even with andy
parkman getting data from the essex
police system
um there seemed to be a difficulty is it
athena or something your system yeah
um
and it occurred to me that something
like the word knife is an entity so if
you've got entity based record system in
a police service which is a modern
system as opposed to records based you
can quickly get anything related to an
area knife a person an address and so on
which makes it very easy for someone an
officer like yourself to actually get
that information you need but we seem to
find that again and again with this
system the analysts are bogged down in
the work they have to do for the force
anyway and we don't get that up-to-date
information i mean as as a matter of
research perhaps we could bring back
from this committee to the essex police
to ask if there's any sort of
improvement we're not looking for
confidential information
is really a statistical level
but that would really help us out
because and when we look at the
published material that's online
it tells you roughly something's going
on
somewhere but it's um it might tell you
in the town but that's about as far as
you will get with it
we did manage to get some decent
analytical material
um
for rayleigh
which we could could not hang on to
because we only had it for the meeting
and we gave it to andy to have it
shredded because it's you know obviously
it's restricted so we can't can't have
that but there is an issue there i think
and it's another council has already
mentioned that this evening
of getting that information and data
um but we don't want to drill down too
much but it would help you as well if
they thought about that
and i don't know if athena seems a bit
of an old system these days
it's not entity
entity-based it's records based is it
new yeah well it should be entity-led
records not record-based in which case
it's easy to get the info because i've
been told of that
yeah
i'll have to apologize i'm not an i.t
expert so i don't really understand the
fine-grained detail of how athena does
well
all it is is you're an entity this
building is and when you search anything
to do with a knife you find it and you
find the area and it's very easy to do
but we don't have that and we we don't
get any kind of accurate information but
we do get a kind of overall picture
which you're giving us which is very
nice but i can sympathize with you
because
when you want that information
it seems to be difficult to get in the
system they've got
can i suggest it might be helpful
it's only a question
oh
your names are taken wilkinson
the only final thing that i wanted to
just mention this evening is that drugs
falls under antisocial behavior quite
often when it's recorded on our systems
and i know that's something that's
particularly concerning to our
communities as it is to us
you'll be aware that we have a number of
and i will call them new teams in
policing we have an operation raptor who
looks at county lines traveling out of
south end and basildon and they do
rochford and castle point as well in
relation to county lines and
particularly in relation to organized
crime groups we have a
team called the falcon team who look at
the organized crime groups for this
district
i'm really we spend a lot of our time um
dealing and managing drugs related
information and incidents just so that
you're aware because it seems to be a
huge focus
i'm conscious that there was an article
in the newspaper i don't know what date
that was but
about
a location in rayleigh i was asked about
that location before that article was
put into the evening echo and what i
would say is we don't we don't have any
information from the public to inform
our work on that one so you know it says
we're never doing anything that that's
what it's suggesting but i keep and i
asked the press office to make sure that
in that press article we did have
information asking people to report
stuff even if it's online and it was
only to somebody i was saying today that
they said oh we saw a vehicle doing
something that looked suspicious we
didn't think we should bother telling
you and i said well
you should because you never know if
that's the
the piece the last piece in that jigsaw
that we needed to connect them to
something that's happening it is with
regret that if you do give us
information or anybody gives us
information we won't always be able to
come back to you and say thank you
and how useful it's been
but i need to just reassure people that
if if we don't know we can't help i'm
not saying that everything that you
report will be able to do something
immediately about it will depend on how
much intelligence we already have but
drugs is something that we're spending a
lot of our time because of the
vulnerabilities involved because of the
risks involved
it is something that we're focusing on
so i want you to reassure you that
that's happening and that's all levels
of drugs from cannabis all the way up
and through thank you a couple more
members have indicated cancer mrs mason
thank you chair
a couple of um aspects around the
priority areas
we've the community safety partnership
has been going for i don't know how many
years but certainly a number of years
and each year you set priority areas now
i hear what you say about the difficulty
in collating statistics with such wide
bands but i do think that when we're
setting priority areas it would be
helpful
to perhaps have some information on how
effective
those areas are because if we're
choosing priority areas and they're not
effective we need to know and if they
are effective we need to know and
without some sort of data or be it
difficult to obtain so i wonder if that
could be looked at going forward so that
perhaps next year's
priority areas
can be quantified in some way
to
show the effectiveness of the community
safety partnership
the other point that i'd
i have concerns about is the
anti-social behaviour aspect
locally
low levels of crime i believe often lead
to higher levels
of crime
i've
been aware of instances where residents
have reported
what low levels of crime damage to
property attempted breaking entry
um vehicle things with cctv
with car numbers with identification
and the police have never contacted the
people involved
or followed up on it and that means that
in future they're not inclined to report
because as far as i appreciate you're
saying you don't go back but when
there's something as clear as a cctv
footage showing someone's car number
plate um driving over property and a
footpath
and causing damage
then i would have thought that was
something that could be followed up
and says to the best of my knowledge it
hasn't been and there was various other
incidents in the same area none of which
to my knowledge of being followed up and
the
general consensus unfortunately of the
people now is there's no point in
contacting the police and that's not
something we want to get across we want
to get across as you say but even if
there is
no obstacle
outcome
each
anti-social behavior even in its minus
form should be reported so i don't know
how that's going to be overcome but i'll
leave that to you
thank you
um so
it is with regret and it upsets me
greatly on a very personal level that
the high harm agenda
that was imposed by our chief officers
earlier on this year late last year
has taken over everything at the moment
and so that is very much our focus and
the direction and steer of our chief
officers it is with regret that that can
be to the detriment of some of the lower
level crime that you're you're you're
talking about we do try as the community
policing team my team in particular do
try to collate that information to see
what the trends and difficulties are so
that we can do something about them i
would urge you to and forgive me i don't
know the details of the instance that
you're talking about please send them
through to me and i'm happy to review
them but i do need to stress that that
resourcing can be a real difficulty for
us
these were sent to the local um
community officer he has all the details
but certainly is that is that warren yes
one's been off sick for a couple of
months so it was prior to that
right but i can give you the details
afterwards if you like there's no
problem okay
thank you
catch the constable
thank you um a few years back we used to
have um an officer in rochford whose job
was
anti-social behaviour and she was so
good at her job that if the local
youths
heard she was in the area they all went
home because
she would like snuff them out and come
down on them big time
is that something we
had likely to see back in the area at
all
so you have um you have town officers
that patrol the rochford area and in
fact they've been pivotal in the
anti-social behavior problems that have
been happening around rochford
but what i'm not going to be able to do
is just dedicate one officer i think you
i mean i've been imposed for
this will be my fourth year so we must
be talking about some considerable time
ago that you're speaking of it was a few
years ago but it wasn't that long ago
that
you know we still remember how well she
did the job i i think and i can't
remember who it was who i was speaking
with earlier
just just to reflect when i joined i had
25 officers on shift at south end and we
also had offices at westcliff shubery
well
that's a completely different world to
the world that we're in today southend
doesn't have 25 officers now to cover
lee westliff shubery southend so
resourcing has changed dramatically
over the years and that is because of
the demand on policing that has changed
so much
the vulnerability agenda the mental
health agenda that
there's so many things that is expected
of policing now it's with regret i'm not
going to be able to
supply an officer just for the rochford
area when you say came down on them what
does that mean
well i've heard instances where if there
was a youth that was causing problems
she would take them home to their
parents
and
the embarrassment of things like that it
soon put a stop to it because the
parents were made more aware of what the
people were doing we do do that
particularly if we can catch young
people on east coasters which is another
bane of all of our lives i'm sure so
it's an it's another problem for us
because people say why don't you do more
about e-scooters and i'm sorry i'm going
off i'm going off piste for a moment
but chasing after a knee scooter just
doesn't always work for us so we
actually have to catch them before
they're actually scooting because we
can't just run them down but we do do
that
but we can't do that so we do take our
young people home it depends on the
circumstances in which we find them
yeah we still do that um i just don't
have one dedicated officer that's going
to be able to to do that just for the
rochester it was it was more of the fact
that she knew her patch she knew
which um because she knew her area she
knew which people were causing the
problems and that's local policing and
that was something that you know was a
very good thing in this area i'm not
saying just rochford but it that can
exist in all areas where the coppers
used to know their patches yep and so
with the op honduras that i mentioned
earlier that's what we're trying to
achieve we're trying to understand who
the young people are who they're
circulating with so that we can know
those individuals better engage with
them differently i'm i'm i'm trying to
explore
they were playing football behind the
shops on
at the airport and i said well why can't
they use the football pitch
over the other side of the roundabout
let's explore how we can get them over
there so we're trying to explore find
out who they are try to engage them in
different ways and that's all stuff that
you just won't see us doing
i don't have one officer that does that
i have a team of officers but they'll do
it at different times so i'm sorry i
can't give you one name but they've got
fine i'll just ask him where we were
with that
can i just say
i've got a lot of sympathy for inspector
caldwell because a lot of these calls
about resources are not hers to make
and i would suggest that perhaps in the
next municipal year we might consider
getting the police and crime
commissioner for essex in to talk about
the policing within the district
okay thank you
council mrs shaw
it's all it's definitely on
thank you kathy um i'd just like to say
with my wallet um i had an issue with um
antisocial behaviour and in my division
for essex i also had a drugs issue
reported it to the police and it's been
solved so think oh this is just thank
you very much for the work that your
officers have done they didn't come back
to me i didn't need them to come back to
me
but the residents have come back to me
and said thank you to me so i want to
pass that thank you on to you thank you
thanks
counselor
thank you chair um kathy
um at the town council i know we pay for
the essex youth workers
do they and
are trying
really just wanted to know on how much
work the police do with essex youth
workers
and to try and reduce the level of
anti-social behavior because
i know that youths are you know
sometimes tired you know with the brush
of
a lot of them causing anti-social
behavior issues and that's what we've
seen
sometimes in rayleigh town centre so
is it something that
councils should explore more and try to
put more resource into with that
you know is it effective in reducing
that do you think i think it's effective
we um
the youth workers don't always want to
associate openly with the police because
they want to build those bridges with
the young people which we totally
understand and we engage with them where
they will allow us to but we do have
really good communications with them and
we direct them in to areas when we
understand that there are particular
problems and they come to us with
particular problems when they think that
the police need to be engaged with them
so
it was something that really concerned
me during covid our young people and and
i know that i
was looking for assistance with that so
i'm grateful for all of their assistance
in working with our young people so i
think it's useful okay thank you
thank you councillor mrs mcpherson
i can hear you but
um
um
um
and it sends a message doesn't it so
that's
not to my um
just to confirm and to back up what
kathy said no community triggers as in
um also called antisocial behavior
behaviour reviews commonly known as
community triggers haven't been
activated this year at all
um personally i believe we do i mean the
anti the community trigger is obviously
a little bit of a last resort i mean its
aim is to um reduce asb and solve it and
it's victim-led um there's a bit of
criticism behind the scenes from groups
whether it is truly effective it was
introduced some time ago now i mean our
duty as local authorities and other
authorities is to
specify the process on our website so
quite explicit about that which as you
know we do and points of contact and
which we do and again timelines
and it very explicit in the
government guidance that the community
trigger process is effectively the last
result so you would expect people to go
through the normal complaints process of
their organizations local government
ombudsman etc so um
in summary i believe we do and
as you know it's explained individually
to clients as and when they approach us
yeah
fine
um councilman person if i could answer
that and um inspector quarter might come
in um the police do have analysts still
they haven't gone away
it's just obviously their capacity is
slightly stretched and reduced and in
previous years
as they have done this year they map a
lot of statistical data and
subsequently they used to put that data
and refine it and put it into a
strategic assessment document on our
behalf as a partnership this year
to put it bluntly so you can just
visualize they've they've done all the
data
but they've dumped it with the
partnership so our task now is to refine
it and that is a new task for the
partnership and they haven't really
necessarily got the immediate skills to
do that so they're all working as a
network to determine how they put
together a strategic document with all
the data they've got they are still
leaning on the analysts but not as hard
as they were before but just to reassure
you the police analysts are very much
still in place they're just not
supporting the partnership in the same
way as they were before that's not a
negative it's just a learning curve for
us
um
crucial crew hasn't changed even though
last year it was the first virtual
online crucial crew exactly the same as
previous years it reaches across the
whole of the district so
and crucial career in particular has
been supported by the essex vulnerable
and
violence and vulnerability unit and it's
in a theatre style now so there's a
bespoke film for young people and
subsequently then there's an interactive
workshop and as you know it's aimed
towards year six so and it helps them
transition with some sort of fairly you
know hard messages for their transition
into secretary school so um and bar and
bus as well as you say reaches across
the whole district and as you know
probably um you know you've seen it in
rayleigh and holbrook and others
it's not it's not really that easy with
partnerships as you know i mean yes you
can measure it in the way of how many
young people have attended it doesn't
necessarily you know to be blunt tell
you um what how useful they've found it
and we do do surveys of all these
certainly the young people that attend
the crucial crew and walk online and
it's quite a challenge to get it all
back
um and we do get some you know comments
about yes very useful you know
frightening and you know things like
that but ultimately you know
the quality of type data is quite
difficult for us and that is an ongoing
as we've recognized risk so
the bar ambassadors used to know from
their website publishes quite a bit of
data themselves and we
the community safety officer talks
regularly with for example the bar and
bus chief executive and crucial crew is
done as a partnership across the whole
network so um you're not necessarily
seeing some hard data here you're just
seeing some softer sort of outcomes from
what pupils have said but that is a
challenge for us getting that back from
the schools
thank you um does the online uh delivery
of the crucial crew
has that got the same impact as the face
to face that you were doing or is it too
early for you to gauge that yet
i think in in reality in person events
are always going to get sort of more
engagement um but you know
i believe the impact's been the same the
reach has been the same we said earlier
that you know it's more flexible
certainly for schools to um adapt and of
course you know reduces travel costs and
and things like that so at the moment
and we're hearing from the schools and
the pupils at the impact is actually
insane but you know in reality we know
in person is always going to get a
slightly better engagement but for the
schools this is working out extremely
efficient way of um getting all this all
their pupils engaged quickly and yeah
and saves a lot around travel costs
[Music]
thank you chair um
through you chair if i may to um louisa
moss
um
louisa can you tell me
um
the success of the j9 initiative which
helps victims of domestic abuse as a as
i understand from kathy earlier that
it's a high area of concern
and have we have seen much take up of
that because
i do think during the pandemic
the rates rose
in domestic abuse as well
is that something that the council was
actively
promoting
and trying to get um
businesses
involved in
and then
uh second question can you tell me
when the cctv network will be
implemented across the district please
um the j9 the j9 program is um i you
know a good question i can't give you a
detailed answer on that and i'll get
back to you as you know it's a promotion
to businesses it's not something we've
particularly um focused on greatly over
the last year
obviously we have been working with our
partners through the south essex
domestic abuse hub and compass which is
the essex provider around domestic abuse
and we've been working with set dab
which is south um you know the south and
essex and thorough domestic abuse board
just to provide a consistent approach
across all of our networks so i will get
back to council newport with specifics
around j9 um but i i can't give you
those this evening because we haven't
necessarily promoted that um to
businesses um
as as perhaps well as we might have done
but um it has been complemented by the
other essex wide activity and especially
because the domestic abuse act is now
out we've all been working collectively
across essex around that messaging
around cctv and my only comment is that
obviously that's gone through the
working party and relevant reports have
been received by um the town council
particularly town council and obviously
you know the community safety officer is
waiting to support them further based on
their decision
i think i'm
alive you hear me
i can never tell if this thing is on
yeah okay yeah if i could just um
3.7 if i'd like to focus on that page uh
scribbled over at 6.2
those are the draft uh priority areas
i'm assuming that they'll be um
firmed up at a later date
um
i'd just like to
to be noted that in october a motion was
submitted by myself
counselors carter mrs carter mrs newport
mrs knight and mrs weston
to that proposed support for everyone to
be safe from finance and harassment and
i do hope that when it's eventually
heard at the council they will support
and implement the proposed actions
to safeguard our residents and this will
support
the draft priority areas of actions that
you've listed here so
it's along the same lines and hopefully
that will support you as well thank you
9.
thank you
thank you
hmm
foreign
thank you chairman so i have great
pleasure in bringing this report to you
this evening looking at the council's
disposal framework
can you hear me now
yes that's better isn't it so thank you
chairman um for letting me bring this
report to you around the council's
disposal framework i'd just like to
bring members attention to a couple of
points if i can first of all in appendix
one
which sets out the framework the
disposal framework um
and this is the the four
four reasons in terms of we will look at
and identify an asset are suitable for
disposal and surplus requirements if it
cannot evidence how it meets at least
one of the objectives outlined above
and that the first of those objectives
is operational we need assets to service
our office accommodation needs for our
staff and partners the second is
financial looking for assets to generate
revenue income and or for capital
investment
the third area is around regeneration
and development looking to regenerate an
area of the district and the fourth is
heritage to promote the heritage offer
for the local area if our assets don't
meet at least one of those objectives
then we'd look to dispose of them
the framework has proved very successful
because although the assets we may not
need them as a councillor anymore our
community certainly does and there's
been some excellent projects that we've
been able to do where those assets have
gone to the community and have made a
significant difference and i'd like to
draw members attention to section 4.1 in
the report please
this is where we have applied the
framework and we've been able to
bring some of those assets back into the
community
i'm particularly pleased with work
that's recently completed around
ashington pavilion
where this is being released now to
ashland parish council and ashington
preschool
[Music]
the the buildings themselves have been
renovated they've had new windows put in
a new roof put on the building itself
looks significantly better than it did a
couple of years ago and actually in
terms of the lease agreement watchful
district council now receives 10 000
pounds a year for that property which is
an excellent piece of work
you also may be aware of the work that's
going on at crown hill the former public
convenience in rayleigh the toilet sir
this site is now will be refurbished and
will be reopened um and i'm pleased to
actually elect to update members this
evening but it's actually going to
become a high quality tap room um
supporting a micro supporting local
micro breweries um and run by an
organization called craft work beer is
limited
and an excellent company that's got a
good track record in south end
and they're going to be using that
for public convenience and they're going
to be refurbishing at their costs so
again a really good piece of news seeing
that investment in rayleigh high street
with a new company coming in there we've
also got the work that's been going on
in hawkwood pavilion with es6 hack space
fantastic there that works being
developed by the community
and
benefiting our community so just some a
couple of examples there
of where this
this piece of work has benefited our
community and we've been able to give
assets back to our residents
there's just a couple of things i'd like
to bring to the committee's attention
um i've listed the four reasons that
we're looking to dispose of assets i do
feel that we could be stronger around
the environmental factors i don't think
we've been strong enough there and
certainly i think going forward
it's one issue that i'd like to see
highlighted in this work to give
consideration to the environmental
impact of our buildings
and certainly if somebody's to take on a
building i think we could be doing more
to ask them to consider the
environmental impact of their work
and finally i guess going forward
there's a question mark over which
pavilions should be looked at next next
which assets should be looked at next i
think there's a feeling that we've done
an awful lot of work within rochford and
hawkwell and some good working in
rayleigh there's probably a need for
great way for me now as well i think to
look at some of the assets over there as
well
um matt did you want to jump in with
anything
it's through you chair fine mate um
thank you councilwood for the um
uh that really useful summary um just to
add to that if it helps members um
the framework is i think only one part
of
of the process um
it's as it sets out and reports it
complements the asset strategy that we
uh approved in 2018 and also the lease
policy which we amended in 2018
similarly so the three taken together
the disposal framework the asset
strategy and the lease policy are the
three guiding principles of how we look
at our assets from a point of disposal
the framework is before us this evening
but it's just a sports note they do link
together and that is referenced in the
report um in terms of those objectives
that councilweb um highlights thank you
thank you chair
first of all i'd like to say um
some of the assets that have been coming
forward have been an
absolute godsend to our local areas
and i particularly have an interest in
hawkwill pavilion as you know i've been
supportive of it from the start
even suggesting it on one of our away
days to get it brought back in to use
and
through the support of councillor
woodson when he was on the assets
this has come into use and it's uh it's
been really well used i have got some
figures
over 300 people are using this weekly so
it's been a
great asset too to the community
i just wondered if there is a policy in
place on your asset strategy framework
for on the environmental impact do you
have that
i didn't quite hear when you was talking
so i'm sorry about that
thank you council gooding um it's a very
good question um when the um i think
it's
intentionally how the the world moves on
in the past few years since we've just
written that framework um council web
highlighted uh environmental aspects of
the framework going forward i think
that's something um that we'd like to
consider and discuss going forward um i
think uh it's a gap in the framework uh
i think it needs to be uh something we
can consider
um when we look at disposals we should
now be considering
how uh if it is a disposal how that
through the expressions of interest we
were used to identify potential new
operators of buildings how could they
support us and the council's objectives
towards our um
objections of carbon neutrality and
sustainability so yes it should be
included
and i think going forward like to make
that happen
thank you
just three aspects i'd like to
comment on
we have such wonderful equipment can you
hear me now
right there's just three aspects as i'd
like to comment on on this report
firstly counselor webb
um
has said that he'll be looking at the
environmental aspects to get that
included in the framework which
obviously i think we would all support
secondly i'd also like them to look at
the potential community value when
they're looking at the disposal of
assets because i think that's something
that is overlooked we shouldn't just
look at monetary values we should look
at values that perhaps aren't so easy to
be measured
um so certainly as a support counselor
with that and hopefully
he can ensure that the other aspect is
looked at as well
the
second
one 3.3
says the disposal of land is transferred
freehold or leasehold interest
i must admit i have concern
with the council giving up freehold
because a freehold
produces normally income
so i would just say that there's a word
of caution there
but the main area that i'd like some
clarification
on is under 4.1
the passive land off of london road the
access strip to raley town sports and
social club
they're suggesting a freehold sale
that piece of land is effectively a
ransom strip
and
should circumstances change and we all
know that with um
the planning situation things can change
quite dramatically especially with a new
local plan
um
that palace of land's
value would change dramatically
so are we going to put a retention
on that land if we we selling it
to make sure that should the
it be used as a ransom strip therefore
consequently
greatly increasing value that there is
some benefit to the council it's
commonly done in commerce i don't know
if the council had ever done it before
but certainly i would be concerned at
selling what is potentially around
sincerity thank you
thank you councilman
mason it answers that questions to
clarify uh that parcel has already been
disposed of um report to executive um
forgive me to check when late last year
i believe that already has been disposed
of in terms of rights across that land
they are maintained for the council and
the sports club in perpetuity but that
asset has already been disposed of yeah
the
the right of acts essex access i accept
it was the uh
uses of ransom street but obviously if
it's being done i thought this was an
imp intention okay thank you
yeah thank you councillor mrs mason um i
certainly welcome my comments around the
environment i think that that's long
overdue and that will certainly has been
taken on the board already so thank you
for that um in terms of the community
value of the assets i would certainly
welcome i think that's one of the the
strengths of this piece of work is where
for example the pavilions have gone back
into community use
and a comment from council of good in
terms of the number of people that are
using that thoracic hackspace is
phenomenal so i would certainly welcome
that being included within the assets as
well i think it's a very sensible point
thank you thank you
uh yeah i'd like to thank you for the um
the disposal framework diagram because
it really does show um a process
actually i can't call it a process chart
that solves problems to do this because
the what i'm going to come to in the
question is obviously it caters for the
1972 act because smaller items are kind
of in the green zone officers can deal
with
and then the where the executive is
involved most of those i kind of would
call them green and amber but when we
get into the red zone and we have had
problems with the asset delivery program
in the current one
where we look at in this chart somewhere
the risk assessment of something that
might go into a red area that's going to
cause
problems with citizens in the community
which we have had
the risk assessment area there we went
for as mrs mason said
a very efficient financial solution it
was almost like a machine it was going
to really deliver everything and it has
had some sticky points so
um
particularly in this one because my
question is that the council engaged in
a public consultation progress after
entering into a partnership and legal
agreements and had the council
considered using problem solving and
risk assessment techniques to define a
model to follow inside of this
um to follow in the disposal framework
to avoid such situations and that was my
suggestion or question
uh because obviously this has been a
learning curve because we're dealing
with social and heritage areas
and for most of what's in this report of
course
they're absolutely beautiful examples of
asset disposal and particularly with
rayleigh we're particularly grateful to
have the playing field which has
recently been signed over so there's
some really good work here so don't go
get me wrong but looking at a a model to
evolve this because in the future we may
encounter similar problems
i have a feeling that sometimes local
government underestimates the abilities
of the citizens
and their involvement
so what i have done i've actually as a
suggestion
sent to council wilson
a suggestion for a little bit of a group
to look at this
just to refine the model yeah
uh in consultation with yourselves
uh to to see if we can apply some of the
techniques and problem solving to it
which you have already by actually
producing this
which is all good stuff you know
so i've not got a knocker of it all
right
don't get me wrong there so um that
that's my question so are you in favor
of looking at that
form of
approach thank you councillor i
certainly welcome um your comments and
if if you wanted to set a working group
up to look at this piece of work in more
detail i would welcome that and would
indeed sit on that group um and take
note of recommendation so yeah thank you
for that contribution please get
involved i think you need to get
involved to be honest
thank you
thank you um
can i refer to um
page 7.1 3.5 um
i think there is um an element already
in the paper around
assets
and their social value for our community
and what i would like to see under that
3.5
if there could be some sort of framework
to actually
measure the impact um when
community groups are taking on
um any of our assets that are
passed to them under value
and then on
page 7.7
it says around at the disposal
the council will dispose of assets by
tender
formal informal by advertising and
inviting sealed bids
perhaps um the officer can explain where
they're advertised how widely because
often if we want to appeal to our local
community groups this has to be aimed
and possibly even targeted at some of
our voluntary groups
and
lastly and this could quite possibly be
a recommendation
in the disposal framework procedure on
7.9
i cannot see any mention
of when
an organization comes to us
as a council showing interest on taking
on one of our assets
unless the officer wants to tell me that
it's in there i would like to recommend
that it is included
and some weight given to that
thank you chairman
thank you chair thank you thank you
person for the question um so in terms
of i think i'll take these out of order
that's okay but if i miss anything do
let me know um in terms of how we market
assets i think it will depend on if
we're looking at a commercial
opportunity or a
person mentions a community opportunity
if we're looking at a potential
commercial opportunity we would work
with
a local agent so in the past we've
worked with um we would have seen as in
crooks recently marketing the former
crown hill toilets she would go through
a formal commercial process inviting
expressive interests and bids to an
agent and following a should expect a
fully commercial process
if we're looking at
a community asset and
councillor gooding mentioned um
the pavilion at hawkwell is another good
example
with those facilities we look more at a
more community-based approach that have
been expressions of interest for example
so we would design a expression of
interest form um which would include
how the asset and the group could meet
the council's objectives so they may be
around enabling communities
and maximizing our assets so how can we
how would that group enable those
objectives of the councils to be met um
and we would score that as you'd expect
on a you know on an objective basis but
also other things such as their
development plan how can he deliver on
those opportunities another thing you
should expect to see in terms of
safeguarding health and safety etc so
it's more community approach those types
of events
groups forgive me
in terms of um the other question
um forgive me counselor just remind me
in terms of measuring the impact of the
community groups
i mean i think that maybe if we form a
small working group that's one of the
things that we consider within that i
think
because that could become quite an
extensive piece of work but actually in
terms of some of the data we've got
already we've seen that through the
essex hackspace um example where we've
already measured the number of people
using that pavilion but i think if we
could take that as part of the working
group and give that some more thought if
that's okay
thank you just
just want to come back on um
one point there um
you mentioned that
it's decided whether the asset the
disposal of the asset goes to a
commercial organization to advertise it
is that correct
so
the weather process works we would
myself in consultation with 151 and the
portfolio holder would identify an asset
for disposal and it's at that point we
would
make a decision whether we felt was it
best is it a community opportunity or a
commercial opportunity depending on
which of those we felt was the best
option we would then design the process
around that
could i just point out there is the
social value act
um that community groups are not to be
disadvantaged in any way
so
you know um you're almost
ruling them out
as opposed to advertising it widely so
that both community groups can apply
um
and tender for
an asset that you have deemed to be
commercial but it may be a building that
they would like to show some interest in
i can certainly note that chairman you
can see that with the portfolio holder
thank you
thank you
councilman mrs mate
thank you
i i was also agreeing with councilman
mcpherson it does seem a little
concerning
that
we're starting off this at the very
beginning deciding whether which route
to go down
when both of those routes could be
equally valuable and i think that's the
point you're trying to make isn't it
that we should keep an open mind on
whether it's a community or commercial
and that decision shouldn't be made at
the onset it should be made further down
the line so that community
organizations have the advantage
and aren't disadvantaged at the outset
which they effectively are
so i don't know if you want to put a
proposal to that uh councilman pearson
but i certainly second it
sorry yeah
can i could i ask a question myself
i've been listening to the debate and um
it sort of ties in with what council mrs
mason and council mrs mcpherson said and
it relates to paragraph 3.5
and
the question i've got really do we have
a sort of scoring mechanism whereby
we look to see if there are different
proposals so for example if there's a
social
is there some sort of algorithm
or some sort of process that we go
through to to look to see
which one we're going to go for and if
there isn't then i'd recommend
thank you chair
i think the simple answer is yes there
is i wouldn't describe it's an algorithm
it's not quite as complicated as that
it's more um
so working with the portfolio holder we
know
what our um the council objections are
in terms of our enabling communities and
maximizing our assets and it may be that
asset can meet both of those
either or one or the other or both so we
do take a view and we can set up that
carefully and it may be our approach
from
a commercial and community group so
maybe able to take on an asset and if
that is the case we can have that
conversation we can undervalue an ascent
disposal if it meets those objectives
and we can create we have done
previously scoring mechanisms that can
enable us to quantify that and put in a
report so we can identify
what that social value is and it may be
providing um
as summer assets do in terms of services
to the community and that may be how we
can justify that or other means so
that's certainly something we do
consider as part of that process okay
thank you
um
no one else is indicating so we had a
number of recommendations that came up
um
the first recommendation was from mrs
gooding
which was about environmental
consideration would you like just to
summarise what the recommendation is
please
okay
okay
okay so
um sonja will you bear to put these up
on the screen so we can see them or not
or i'll just read them out
okay yeah
okay thanks
um the second recommendation i think was
coming from council mrs mason which is
looking at how we measure community
value
it was
it was to add that as an aspect under
the framework
along with the environment
i think community is actually
more wide ranging than social
it's just that social value has a
specific definition
um at government level and in terms of
red book valuations um in that case if
we put both him then we're covered
aren't we thank you
thank you for the clarification
so which would value
social values social value is
thank you share social value is the
correct term are you happy with that
council
not really no i'd like to communicate
and socially yes that's what i've asked
for yes sir thank you
chairman if you don't mind your
counselor
but um also can be the add-on they may
take in apprenticeships or provide
services
i just preferred it to be wider but if
everyone else disagrees then i'll go
with that
yes thank you chairman um my
recommendation would be that during the
disposal of assets
our
community groups are not disadvantaged
in their
ability and opportunity
to bid for any of these assets
thank you
i'll type it up
members while um while angela's typing
this up we'll have a five minute
comfort break
my way
um
okay members um
i've
i'll read out the um the recommendations
can you all see them
i'll read them out anyway
to inc first recommendation is to
include consideration of environmental
and community stroke social value issues
in the disposal framework
to ensure that during disposal of assets
community groups should not be
disadvantaged in their ability to bid
for assets
and that a working group be established
under the auspices as the portfolio
holder for commercial business local
economy and leisure to consider the use
of risk assessments to inform disposal
options
members i propose to vote for those on
block unless any one
you want them separately
okay
so
the
yeah okay thank you
so the first recommendation is to
include consideration of environmental
and community stroke social value issues
in the disposals framework could those
indicate in favor please raise their
hand
okay that's unanimous thank you members
the second recommendation is to ensure
that during disposal of assets community
groups should not be disadvantaged in
their ability to bid for assets
for those in favor please raise their
hands
thank you members that's unanimous
and
recommendation number three that a
working group be established under the
sorry
sorry sorry chairman i'm just wondering
if a standalone meeting that's task
orientated might be better than setting
up a whole new working group as i'm very
conscious of officer time um absolutely
agree with the need to look at this
piece of work
but would do our review maybe consider a
single standalone meeting rather than
ongoing working group please thank you
i think
it's there i understand what you're
saying
i think it's there so recommendation
three is that a working group be
established under the auspices of the
portfolio holder for commercial business
local economy and leisure to consider
the use of risk assessments to inform
disposal options
could those members in favor please
indicate
look at those against please indicate
okay and no
so there were nine four
and five against so that recommendation
is carried forward
but bear in mind this is a
recommendation that's going forward to
the executive
noted thank you chairman thank you
so members there is
one further recommendation um which is
to note the implementation of the
disposal framework since its inception
is that noted members
thank you
item eight is the key decisions document
members are there any questions on the
key decisions document
okay
thank you members moving on to item nine
which is our work plan
um
members looking ahead to the meeting on
the fifth of april uh we'll be in a
position to consider a report from the
carbon neutral working group
um the stakeholder engagement item will
be rolled forward uh into the next
municipal year so this was our
stakeholder engagement
sorry council wilkinson yeah
thank you show um this is the meeting
you asked me to remind you about our
previous conversation around
the uh planning enforcement yes thank
you um
so the
an issue has been raised about how the
enforcement this has come from a number
of of members across the district about
how planning enforcement is
operating within the district um
and
what i've proposed to do is support that
have a a
member work member-led working group on
this and to use that at the start of the
next municipal year so that will be
added in for next year
so the background to this is that there
are a number of uh cases that have been
raised and brought to me um
about the perception that perhaps
enforcement isn't being done on certain
buildings so buildings get planning
approval and then what's actually
constructed isn't necessarily what was
in the drawings so it's a working group
to look at how that
can be taken forward
council mrs mason
thank you mr chairman there were other
items i believe on here certainly there
was the outside spaces working group
that seems to have fallen off and
normally we leave those on there for the
new review committee to um
consider in in the new municipal year
that they seem to have got lost but
i believe from the last report there
were three or four items that hadn't
been incorporated
can you say which ones they are well the
only one i can remember was the outside
spaces working group the
outside spaces working group historic
i believe there were some others and i'm
just going by memory so
i could be wrong
but
perhaps someone else has got some old
documents and can look them up yeah
sorry
oh that's better is that better
it keeps turning itself off i don't know
why sorry yeah
right i'll i will look at that counselor
milne
um yeah just one issue because
unfortunately he's going back to the
previous session before the working
i had a suggestion or a recommendation
that we look at the model because this
model or the framework and the previous
item seven did not include
a specified methodology for dealing with
public engagements if we risk assess
something that is really impinges
heavily in the social heritage area
and although there is a risk assessment
there in number three up there and i had
actually written out a document about
that
yeah we can't go back on the item but i
do
i
i will take an action to take your paper
and and present that to uh matt hold
wyatt
and i think your suggestion was that
there'd be a potentially a working
member working group on that yeah yeah
okay well that's fine i'll thank you
yeah
i thought you forgot me
um and then um
the
yeah the an update i gave an update at
the last meeting but i've had a further
update from louisa moss about the
homeless and rough sleeper
strategy
and
that will be ready around
the first draft will be ready around
june so we'll roll that over into next
year next municipal year as well
okay
so are there any other questions on the
work plan members
okay thank you members um just before we
finish on that i'd like to ask angela
hutching she's going to give us an
update on some of the reporting for the
partnership program
thank you chair
members just to confirm that following
the full council meeting at the end of
january
the rochford and brentwood strategic
partnership work is um commencing
and i should be in a position to bring a
report to this
meeting in june and taking a report to
executive at approximately the same time
so um that will be the next item for
your work plan and the contents of that
june report will discuss and set out the
ongoing work plan for the remainder of
the program so again that will inform
your work programme for the rest of next
municipal year
thank you angela
okay members
no one else is indicating so
that's the final agenda item
so the meeting is closed at
2100 hours thank you